it can be heard for miles
it's been like this for almost a week
spitting and splintering over a thousand
feet in the air
it's now feeding two rivers of lava now
flowing through la palma on the
right-hand side of this valley is
ascencion's home
she watched the eruption from her
kitchen window and ran the police came
that we had to go we had to go we had to
go
and
we left everything we put the places in
and we left our house and
to today we haven't known about nothing
about our house
i am very nervous
all our life is there
we built it
with our hands and
it's all our life
her family are among 7 000 people to
have been evacuated
those tasked with moving them know many
will now be homeless
there are people who are not going to
find their house after this because it's
five seven eight meters under the ground
people there are people here who have
been here for all their life they have
grown here they have their sons here
so it's quite hard for them to leave the
house because of a volcano
the lava's slowing pace has brought time
for those eager to get out
as they left spain's king felipe and
queen leticia travelled in to meet
evacuees
coming to their aid too is the entire
island community
this sports hall is brimming with
donations not just with physical items
but mental health support too
social workers are going to work with
the families and we'll organize all the
donations that we have here
we will cover their essentials and then
later we can perhaps help them with
finding a new home and everything they
need for it
now billowing high above the mountains
the ash is threatening airspace
some flights in and out of the island
have been delayed
we saw from the sky the reason why the
black cloud signposting the disaster
but for locals it's not an easy
neighbour to ignore the unpredictability
is what many fear the most
asharanag sky news